it's time for the launch in chrono scope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene wit nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our toy
editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chrono scope Larry lisseur of the
CBS television news staff and Kenneth
Kramer executive editor of Business Week
magazine our distinguished guest for
this evening is Charles our slide jr.
president of the National Association of
Manufacturers mr. Slye upon your
election in 1953 as the president of the
National Association of Manufacturers
you pledged industries wholehearted
cooperation with the Eisenhower
administration have you had any occasion
to change your views no I think we want
very much to cooperate with the
Eisenhower administration that does not
necessarily mean of course that we're
going to agree with everything they do
NM set certain policies which it wishes
to follow based on principles which we
believe are sound and we believe in
going straight down the line for those
principles once in a while we don't
happen to agree with the administration
as there was the case in connection with
the excess profits tax but we would like
to cooperate with any Administration in
office in this country to build a
greater America well may I ask you sir
what about the president the present
administration's plans to lower tariffs
well now you're on a subject that I
can't talk about very well because n-am
has no position on tariffs we find that
our members have such widely divergent
opinions and views because of the
businesses in which they're connected
that we don't feel NM can speak
effectively for it's over 20,000 members
on the matter of tariffs some of our
people want high tariffs some low and we
feel that because of the widely
divergent opinions we cannot have a
position on tariffs as such but if we
don't lower tariffs what can yup and
Asia do to keep their economies healthy
sir well as I say we have no position on
tariffs I think there are other matters
in connection with foreign trade which
are important I think that many things
can be done to help Europe help itself
I've been very much encouraged recently
to read about the meeting of the six
powers in Western Europe Holland Belgium
Luxembourg Italy West Germany and France
I understand their meeting to try to
break down the economic barriers which
now exists between their countries and
allow a free flow of goods and services
and people within their borders I think
any such breakdown of those economic
barriers and making a united whole out
of those six countries will do a very
great deal to promote the economic
well-being of Europe and I think other
steps along that same line should be
taken if Europe is going to grow strong
economically mr. Slye another subject of
considerable importance is taxes people
who do their Christmas shopping early I
think have already been renewed to the
idea that there are some terrific excise
taxes imposed on certain goods is it
true that the nem wants to have even
more excise taxes imposed know we we
believe that the present excise tax
system is a veritable hodgepodge of
discrimination do you mean luxury Texas
sir we said some people call them luxury
taxes but I don't think any of us here
tonight would agree that an electric
light bulb is a luxury and yet electric
light bulbs are taxed at twenty percent
the people that drive their cars to work
in this country today or
are in the millions and they need those
cars I don't think cars are luxuries and
yet they're taxed at seven percent I
could go down a long list of literally
thousands of items that are now subject
to excise taxes we think that all those
excise taxes which we believe our
discriminatory should be done away with
entirely and that in place of those
texts is not a new tax but in place of
those discriminatory excise taxes we
should impose a flat-rate manufacturers
excise tax on all manufactured products
except food and food products and accept
the liquor and tobacco which
historically in this country have been
taxed separately and we feel that liquor
and tobacco should continue to be taxed
separately now it happens that a flat
rate tax of approximately five percent
on the manufactured goods would bring in
the same amount of revenue as is now
being brought in through the very highly
discriminatory taxes which are now in
effect well isn't the problem of this
administration to raise additional
revenues and if you take away the luxury
taxes you replace it with a general
manufacturers tax with that bring in
additional revenues or just make up for
what has been lost out of the luxury tax
it would not bring in any additional
revenues my fear is that the present
discriminatory system will not continue
to bring in what it is now bringing in I
think there are very definite
indications of that fact for instance
last year the movie industry very nearly
got their admissions tax removed under
our plan all admission taxes would be
removed all services would be removed
from taxation today of course telephones
telegraphed a transportation of persons
transportation of freight and many other
services are taxed we would do away with
all those service taxes you mentioned
discrimination I've often heard it said
that if you put in a across-the-board
excise tax or a general sales tax that
that would be discriminatory against
people in the lower income brackets at
is commonly said I don't believe it true
no I don't think it is you see we would
exempt food and food products we would
exempt all services the over fifty
percent in fact I've seen figures that
indicate it as high as sixty-five
percent of the expenditures of the low
and middle income groups are made up of
food and food products and services such
as rent and so on and those things under
our plan would be exempt and actually we
find that the low and middle income
groups would not pay any more in the
aggregate than they're paying today well
who would bear the burden of such taxes
mr. Slye wouldn't the retailer's add
their markup on top of the tax I'm glad
you mentioned that and I might point out
this applies not only to exercises it
applies to every type of tax of which we
can think people pay taxes they always
will and the idea that a corporation can
pay without hurting any people is a
fallacy in other words some people
unfortunately think that because a tax
is applied to a corporation that some
way or other the brick and mortar and
machinery are going to pay the taxes
people pay the taxes either the
employees are going to be penalized the
management the owners are the consumers
when corporation taxes are applied and
people are always going to pay taxes and
that they will pay consumption taxes or
consumer Texas well when we were
removing the taxes from the corporations
and passing them on to the consumer this
way no we don't we we don't plan to do
that at all we merely replace the
present discriminatory taxes with a fair
and equitable distribution of the
present excise tax load you see today we
truly have a hidden excise tax system
because I doubt whether any one of our
audience realizes that there are today
thousands literally thousands of items
that are taxed and the rates range from
465,000
of a cent a pound on sugar up to
twenty-five percent on many items that
is truly a hidden system because nobody
can keep track of all the taxes they're
forced to pay but a five percent excise
tax flat rate on all manufactured
products except food and food products
would be a tax that everyone would know
about it would not be a hidden tax at
all Oh My yes you just what the
difference is between a general sales
tax and an excise tax I think the main
difference would be the point at which
it was levied in other words a general
sales tax is commonly thought of as
being levied at the retail level while
the excise tax generally speaking is
considered to be applied at the
manufacturers level are you in favor
then of having lower income taxes and
put more of the burden on on the excise
tax arrangement no we are in favor as I
say I'm replacing the revenue now
brought in through the discriminatory
system by a flat rate tax now I will say
this that if it was possible later on to
reduce income taxes or to reduce taxes
in general I think that the first step
probably should be the reduction of
income taxes rather than a reduction of
excise taxes are you in favor of the
planned reduction in income taxes that I
believe is suppose yes fair enough year
very definitely mr. Slye the cost of
living is going up as we've seen by the
recent indexes and it looks as though
labor will be asking for more money do
you manufacturers propose any changes in
the taft-hartley law well we believe
that the taft-hartley law generally
speaking has been a good labor law we
think it can be a much better labor law
than it has been through fair and
impartial administration I do think that
it should be pointed out that it is only
fair that they're not be any monopoly in
our economy whether it be in business or
in government or in labor was the final
question mr. Slyde I could ask you
something you started your own furniture
business I know in the
depth of the depression do you feel
we're on the verge of a recession now no
I certainly do not and I decry those
prophets of doom that are always trying
to predict us into a recession or a
depression I can remember back in 1943
one of the labor leaders of this country
predicted that immediately after World
War two there would be 15 million
unemployed people in this country now
that has never come about fortunately
and I see no reason today with the
tremendous growth that lies before this
country for any marked recession or
depression I think the main danger is
psychological and I think that if we
will work for the future that we can
attain we will attain us and I certainly
hope we do well thank you very much mr.
slaying pleasure to have you here
tonight the opinions you've heard our
speakers expressed tonight have been
entirely their own the editorial board
for this edition of the launch in chrono
scope was Larry lesser and Kenneth
Kramer our distinguished guest was
Charles or slide jr. president of the
National Association of Manufacturers